Hey, did you take a look at the cover of this week's "Celebrity Tattler"?
No, I don't usually read those Hollywood gossip magazines.
Me neither, but I just had to pick this one up.
Check it out!
Let's see.
Well, Brad Pitt is breaking up with a girlfriend and divorcing his wife.
How interesting!
No, not that. Look what it says at the bottom.
You mean here?
"Entire Cast of Friends Takes a Holiday at a Nudist Colony."
Yeah, isn't that amazing?
Not really.
Are people that bored with their own lives that they need to read about stuff like this?
I guess so. You know, it's strange,...
...I just felt like I had to buy the magazine when I saw it.
One thing about TV and Movie stars,...
...they're always getting themselves into some kind of trouble.
That's very true.